while he's going to say AP words also
about the Russian task force and then
Seth is going to go through the details
this may seem a little bit longer than
we would normally do as an introduction
but there are four decisions that were
made today and it's important that
everybody understands what sits behind
each of those four so please bear with
us and the press release will be ready
to be issued um as soon as we've
finished or hopefully just before
Sam over to you Jackie thank you
um and in the words of the last four
British prime ministers I don't really
intend to detain you too long but uh I
do have um quite a uh a level of detail
here from the council meetings uh over
the last two days so first of all good
evening to those of you who are in our
time zone I recognize there are some of
you on the screen that are in slightly
uh less hospitable uh time zones but
thank you each and every one of you for
joining us
um as you know the council has just had
uh three days
uh who will be hosting our 2024 uh World
Athletics race walking Team
Championships and tauren uh in the
craving Pomeranian region of Poland who
will be hosting our 2026 World Athletics
indoor championships uh both countries
as you know have hosted successful
athletics events in the past
and we know they all have a strong
athletic support and fans so
congratulations to those two cities uh
yesterday we also heard from the team
hosting uh the World Championships later
this year in Budapest and they reported
to us live from the stadium it looked a
lot different from when I was last there
and they did so on the 150 days to go
progress is good and we're really
looking forward to being there for what
I know will be an exhilarating
championships now if I may move on to
today
the world Athletics Council has already
made a number of important decisions
regarding the future participation of
the Russian and Bella Russian Athletics
federations and the amendment of
Eligibility regulations for athletes who
are transgender and who have differences
of sexual development DSD
the council agreed to the reinstatement
of the Russian Federation Rusev
following seven years of suspension and
that of course was due to the egregious
institutional doping violations however
athletes officials and supporting
personnel
from Russia and Belarus are still
excluded from competition for the
foreseeable future due to Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
I will hand over to rooner Anderson
chair of our Russia task force to
summarize the decisions and the lengthy
seven-year journey to that decision
rooner thank you for being with us over
to you
thank you Seb and as you mentioned I
delivered my final report to council
today in my capacity as the independent
chair of the Russia task force
I did remind Council that Rusev was
originally suspended from membership in
November 2015 due to its whole scale
breach of its anti-doping obligations
and that in November 2021 Congress
resolved to continue that suspension
until Rusev had met all of the
reinstatement conditions set by Council
my advice counsel today that those
conditions have now been met
sorry first an in independent audit team
has confirmed that Rusev has met all of
the detailed kpis and other requirements
set out in the reinstatement plan that
Council approved in March 2021
and second Rusev has accepted a detailed
set of post reinstatement conditions
designed to ensure there is not no
backsliding from the significant
progress that it has made to date
these are in addition to the other
special requirements that Rusev will
have to meet as a category a member
Federation under the rules of the roller
topics
I told Council that the task force met
with Rusev president Peter ibanov and
his senior management team in person in
Istanbul last week
they satisfied us that the meeting that
they understand the importance of these
requirements and that they are committed
to complying with them
given all this the task force
recommended that Council lift Rusev
suspension and reinstate it to
membership on the basis that it has to
comply with all of the above mentioned
requirements for at least three years
with such compliance to be monitored by
the AIU that is the Athletics Integrity
unit at ruseop's cost
uh Council adopted that resolution and
therefore the task force work has come
to an end
thank you we'll have you finished
yes
correct oh Bruna thank you sorry I I
thought from my moment your
um screen had Frozen uh Runa look thank
you for that I I'm I'm sure there may be
some questions that will come your way
uh towards the end of the uh at the end
of the uh press conference but uh let me
just digress for a moment because
um I'd just like to take this
opportunity I know I speak on behalf of
all my Council colleagues and
particularly those members of the task
force
for the Herculean work that you and the
team have done over the last seven years
uh it's been exemplary uh it's been
painstaking and I know at times it's
been painful
um this work was absolutely essential uh
it followed a process and we and I like
to think uh that those athletes that are
going to be competing I hope in future
years in Russia do so uh with the
confidence of the rest of the sport we
still have some way to go
um I think it is worth pointing out that
alongside this reinstatement uh there is
a list of 35 special conditions to be
applied for a period of three years
uh with a review at the end of that
period to determine whether or not it is
necessary to maintain those conditions
as they are or with variations for a
further period
the council then approved the
recommendation to continue to exclude
Russian and Bella Russian athletes and
officials from all our world Athletics
series events World Championships our
Continental tour meetings and other
International competitions and that is
for the foreseeable future because of
the invasion and the ongoing war in
Ukraine the full details of exclusion
are included in the press release that
will be issued at the end of this press
conference both federations have 24
hours to respond to the council's
decision for Council again to consider
uh the council has also approved the
establishment of a working group to
advise and recommend to the council the
conditions that would need to be met for
the restrictions on athletes and
officials from rusath and the Belarus
Athletics member Federation
participating uh in World athletic
series events to be lifted this will be
set up in the next few weeks let me now
move on to the DSD and transgender
regulations
the world Athletics Council has today
taken the decisive action to protect the
female category uh in our Sport and to
do so by restricting the participation
of transgender and DSD athletes
the decision was taken in consultation
with a number of stakeholders including
40 member federations
our coaches our athletes and through the
athletes commission as well as a range
of other community groups including
trans groups un experts the
international Olympic Committee and para
Athletics
let me if I may start with the
transgender athletes
the majority of those consulted stated
that transgender athletes should not be
competing in the female category many
believe there is insufficient evidence
that trans women do not retain advantage
over biological women and more more
evidence than any physical advantages
have been ameliorated before they are
willing to consider an option for
inclusion into the female category
unlike DSD athletes there are no
transgender athletes competing in
international competition in athletics
and no observations therefore exist from
the front line in our case the field of
play across the different disciplines
that are specific to our sport I.E
endurance running Sprints throws jumps
and Road events
where the science is insufficient to
justify maintaining testosterone
suppression for transgender athletes the
council agreed it must be guided by our
overarching principle which is to
protect the female category
we cannot in all conscious leave our
transgender regulations as they were at
five nanomoles per liter for at least
one year when we were unsure about the
impact of doing so across all our
disciplines so we need to know more and
we need to know more now
the council has agreed to exclude male
to female transgender athletes who have
been through male puberty from female
world-ranking competitions from March
the 31st at this year
however in order to do further research
while transgender eligibility guidelines
we will be establishing a working group
whose remit will be to consult
specifically with transgender athletes
to seek views on competing in athletics
to review and maybe commission
additional research where there is
currently limited research and to put
forward recommendations to council the
working group will include an
independent chair up to three council
members two athletes from the athletes
commission a transgender athlete from
Athletics three representatives of Our
member federations and representatives
of the world Athletics health and
science department
let me if I may now turn to our DSD
eligibility
the world's Athletics Council today
decided to reduce the testosterone
threshold for DSD athletes to 2.5
nanomoles per liter across all our
events
we have DSD athletes competing in the
unrestricted events in our Sport and we
have 15 years of data observations and
information directly from our own Sport
and of course our DSD athletes
as far as our medical manager is aware
there is no relevant athlete by that I
mean DSD athlete in jumping or throwing
events
among the 13 athletes the medical
manager has been in contact with and
that we mentioned in our consultation
paper all have declined testosterone
suppression or a complete medical
assessment
because of this they have not been
eligible to compete in the restricted
events since 2019.
of those athletes still competing in the
unrestricted events around half are
competing in running events over the
mile and the other half are competing in
distances below 400 meters
we want to give the DSD athlete to our
already competing in our sport I.E and
the unrestricted events all those
outside of 400 to 1 mile the opportunity
to resume competition but our scientific
advice is that six months is the minimum
period necessary to ensure their
naturally high testosterone levels are
no longer giving them an advantage over
biological women
these interim Provisions are only for
athletes who are currently competing in
non-restricted events throwing jumping
running below 400 meters or beyond the
mile the interim Provisions do not apply
to the previously restricted events
the six-month duration chosen for the
interim provision is a compromise to
provide and allow the relevant athletes
who previously competed in unrestricted
events an opportunity to compete in
compliance with our DSD regulations that
were approved today
the six-month period is in line with the
required suppression for the current DSD
regulations and according to the
available science it is enough to bring
hemoglobin levels a key determinant of
performance from natural male levels to
normal female levels it is unlikely to
be sufficient to reduce enough
performance advantage in the power
strength based disciplines therefore we
believe that the interim Provisions are
likely to level the playing field in
running events beyond the mile where 55
of our identified relevant athletes
compete it is likely to still be
insufficient to reduce the unfair
Advantage the relevant athlete
experiences in sprinting events where 45
percent of the identified relevant
athletes are currently competing
DSD athletes who have been competing in
the unrestricted events can apply to
benefit from A reduced six-month period
to maintain testosterone levels under
2.5 nanomoles per liter provided they
apply and suppress their testosterone
level to two Nan at 2.5 nanomoles per
liter before 1 July of this year 2023 so
none of these athletes will be eligible
to compete in the world Athletics
Championships in Budapest in August they
will be eligible to compete in other
events after that six-month period
including the Paris Olympic Games next
year if and only if they maintain their
testosterone at the required level
I know there is a lot of detail there
but I'm going to hand over to Jackie at
this moment thanks
um the if you can put questions in the
chat it's going to be a lot easier than
just identifying everybody and then um
on pinning you or
um allowing you to speak so if we can do
that that would be better
um see you've had your hand up for ages
but can you can you type it to put it as
you speak hopefully
and Rob I know you just asked that
question
we'll just give you a few moments
all right I'll type it now Jackie
hi Martin
Rob I do understand it's better for TV
but as I said it is quite difficult to
um unmute everybody individually so if
you wait till the end if you like and if
there is a we can ask you can ask a
question directly out
thanks
okay let's see so Hi Sam how do you feel
about the ioc trying to allow Russians
to compete as neutrals despite Ukraine
war still going on
uh Martin height look I think the
position the council has taken today is
very clear there's no ambiguity about it
um the Primacy for the
um decision around uh eligibility
arrests with the International
Federation
um that is something that was agreed at
the court of arbitration when we were
out last there over the Russian doping
violations uh it is uh accepted by the
international Olympic Committee and that
is what we have decided today uh that we
felt it was in the best interests of our
sport so we determine eligibility and
for our World Championship events uh for
the foreseeable future the exclusion uh
remains
okay um Eddie regarding
um is that eddiepie regarding Russia and
Belarus is World Athletics Consulting
with trying to get in sync with the ioc
program
um Eddie I think the decision that was
Council made today was actually the
opposite of what the ISE is trying to do
um Rachel is it still World efforts
position that Russia will need to leave
Ukraine in order for his athletes to be
allowed to compete in international
Athletics well um that was my instinct
in um in Rome as our council meeting
when I got asked that question before
Christmas it remains my instinct but I
think that will also fall firmly within
the remit of the working group that will
want to look at that process I'm very
keen to establish that working group The
working group that rooner Anderson
chaired so abley uh into uh the uh
doping violations in Russia proved to be
a a really good process we were much
stronger for that process and we got to
where we wanted to uh when it comes to
the working group here clearly they will
want to make those types of decisions
what are the metrics by which those
athletes can come back into competition
but the Council on the basis of what we
know now uh were very clear that this
was not the right moment but I do think
having a working group chaired
independently that can now start looking
at what that process going forward might
look like and what it would take to
remove that exclusion from athletes and
officials in Russia and Belarus okay
thank you
um Alex has got a question which I might
just answer if that's right and you said
a bit confused over DSD uh can they
compete in the restricted events in
testosterone levels and meekly new
criteria so in the restricted events DSD
athletes need to take their uh
testosterone suppress testosterone 2.5
for two years so it's the provision the
special provision that does not apply to
the restricted events it only applies to
the unrestricted is that clear Alex I'm
sure you'll tell me if it's not
Mark I don't remember you've officially
said if you'll run for a third term so
uh I I haven't but I'm very happy to
declare that I will
now
that you'll be pleased to know there are
not too many shop faces uh around the
table
um okay Sarah hi thanks for making the
time to clarify the Russia Bella Russian
police Belarus policy if Russian
Belarusian athletes are excluded from
World athletics events I World
Championships are they ineligible to
seek qualification to the Paris Olympics
yes
thanks Seb
okay
um
hi
um how is the situation of the Paris
2024 mixed race
uh mixed race walking event right now
there are only 16 months left and the
athletes don't know what distance they
should train
um we made the decision in the council
I'm not actually sure when yeah no so we
we yeah when are we going to relay that
it goes to the is the ioc's executive
board will be discussing it at the end
of next week yeah so they will know very
definitely yeah
um Rob I've been told by RIT that um we
can um we can
unmute you so you can ask a question
sure
um hi sir hi Rob hi there
is this the most difficult decision
you've had to take excluding trans women
from events
look none of the decisions that we've
made in this Council have been easy
decisions I mean that actually if I may
say so that has been the mark the
Hallmark of the last two councils we've
been prepared to tackle these issues
head on in the past they'd have been
allowed to drift or kicked into the long
grass
um that's not the nature of my
leadership here and it's certainly not
the instincts of my Council so look we
have we entered it as you know we
entered a consultation
um some months ago we did so because we
wanted to provoke debate it was really
important that we heard from all our
stakeholders including the athletes the
coaches the member federations my
goodness we heard from them so the
Judgment that we took once we had sifted
our way through that consultation
um was I believe in the the best
interests of our sport the working group
however is very clear uh that you know
we want to be able to uh discuss and
communicate directly to the trans
Community I'm going to ask a transgender
athlete to chair that working group
we're not saying no forever and
prevailing understanding changing
science but I think our Instinct was
that while there is uncertainty about
that science it is not as robust as the
science and the information the data
that we have on the 15 years of work
that we've done doing on the front line
with DSD athletes and where that science
wasn't as robust as in DSD we decided
that it was uh it was impossible to
maintain the transgender regulations at
the level that they were and I think
that is the right decision but we are
very clear that that working group will
look at any prevailing or or changing or
furthering of our understanding in that
space we don't know enough we do now
need to know more and that is the
journey that we're on but we weren't
prepared to to risk the female category
on that basis there are athletes now who
will feel excluded and discriminated
against what is your message to them as
they feel
this pain perhaps
that the decision that the Council made
is a primarily principled based decision
and that is the overarching need to
protect the female category this is what
our sport is here to do and I think the
council has done that today
Rachel I've got a question from you
um does World Athos anticipate its
policy on transgender athletes will
remain the same as it's been announced
today through the final qualifications
and trials for the Paris Olympics yes it
will
okay any further questions
sorry I know it's easier to speak but
it's a it's a bit of a challenge for us
to unmute individuals so
hi David do you expect any legal issues
over the new transgender policy UK
Athletics have flagged legal issues
um in the UK
uh David hi
um it's possible
look I I made this point to the council
today that all the decisions we've taken
have their challenges they have medical
challenges they have scientific
challenges they have legal challenges
they certainly have communications
challenges so look if if that is the
case then we will do what we have done
in the past which is vigorously defend
our position
and the overarching principle for me is
we will always do what we think is in
the best interest of our sport
thanks Seb
any other questions
no the press release I think is heading
out soon so yeah all the details will be
in there including the links to the task
force report also to the full
transgender and DSD regulations so you
can um read them all at your leisure Rob
Harris has asked did you think of an
open category
that the that was part of the
consultation various conversations came
back various overtures
but we think at this moment we have
reached uh the right uh we've got the
right approach and that's where we are
okay uh Sarah yeah Sarah hi have you
spoken with the ISE and or Thomas back
about the decision to exclude Russia and
Ballarat and Bruce from athletics events
and if so what's been the substance of
your conversation to that point
look I've had ongoing dialogue with the
international Olympic Committee I am
after all an international Olympic
Committee Member uh and that dialogue
has been you know been running actually
since the uh illegal invasion of Ukraine
um I attend will be attending uh
meetings on Monday uh with fellow ioc
members and actually soon after that uh
wearing my International Federation hat
as well so there will be plenty of
opportunities but I don't think I think
you can probably conclude the ISE is not
in any doubt about where I sit on that
issue
thank you and that was the same question
from David
um
any other questions
no
you you oh hold on yes hi Mark
um did Sergey book attend your meeting
and what was his position about Russia
um Sergey did attend
um the meeting and I think you can
conclude that he was on the majority uh
view uh on the exclusion of Russia or
Belarusian athletes
okay so all of you you know how to reach
us so do um compact after any other
questions or if anything else is unclear
um and as I said the press release will
be
um hopefully into your inboxes um in the
next few minutes so thank you for your
time and your patience and um please do
come back to us if there is anything
unclear thank you
thanks guys